[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
lovely to see you this evening tonight
Piers Morgan uncensored with me Rosanna
Lockwood this is what we're going to be
talking about could Prince Harry's U.S
visa be under threat over admissions of
drug taking cocaine cannabis magic
mushrooms he told all in his book but
did he tell the officials was he given
special treatment and if he was how on
Earth is that fair
the government could rewrite the law to
Define what makes a woman barring a
trans women from Single Sex spaces like
female Hospital Wards and sports events
we'll be discussing where that could
leave an already very heated very toxic
route
plus Melania Trump who is loyally by her
husband Donald's side throughout his
presidency but she was glaringly absent
from his court hearing yesterday where
is she and what must she be making of
all of this
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Rosanna Lockwood
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Rosanna Lockwood my question to you
this evening where is the honor where is
the decorum it's what I found myself
asking today after those pictures of
former U.S presidents sat in court
pleading not guilty to 34 felony counts
of falsifying business records about
extramarital Affairs now whatever you
think about this particular prosecution
the behavior the Affairs the scheming as
it was called which was outlined in the
charge seat it paints a picture doesn't
it and of course of course I'm not
saying he's the first he is not the
first leader to be caught up in
impropriety whilst in the Oval Office I
know that it doesn't matter whether
you're right or left but I think it's
forever fascinating how politicians
sleep at night over the deafening knocks
of the skeletons in their closets and
how they can pretend everything is okay
knowing the truth always outs now you
can call me an equal opportunity critic
of poor behavior on this in Royal
circles meanwhile the quest
continues as well renewed calls for
Prince Harry's U.S visa application to
be released to see if he declared his
prior drug use which he himself
mentioned no less than 12 times in his
own book now those pushing for the
release of his application argue he
shouldn't be above U.S laws either
no human is perfect I'm not saying that
I'm certainly not but is it too much to
hope that positions of power and
influence should be held by people of
Integrity perhaps that's why we've seen
the invitation today to the coronation
next month sent out by King Charles and
queen Camilla now this did surprise some
the couple now dropping the title of
Queen consoles and going full Queen on
this invitation the culmination of
remarkable Journey for Camilla who
without doubt has proven herself to be
hard-working and graceful in her role
all of this begging the question how
forgiving can the public be and what are
the qualities needed to win in the court
of opinion perhaps perhaps it's glitzy
New York award ceremonies like the one
Meghan Markle is attending next month to
be recognized as a quote Global role
model by one of her close friends
forget how hard women like you and so
many others before you fought for us to
just be where we are right now well it's
just I mean when you if you don't vote
you don't exist
I mean you know it is the only place
where we're all equal
or perhaps it takes more than that let's
find out shall we or at least try and
have a go joining me is the Royal editor
of the London evening standard very nice
to have you this evening also the author
of our King Robert Johnson and
journalist and author of the case for
cancer culture Ernest Owens look thank
you both very much for joining us on
this discussion Let's uh we laid out the
the claims there about uh Harry and
about his U.S citizenship
um it just is a story that won't go away
is Harry should he be treated
differently from any other citizen
absolutely not I mean I I recently
applied for an i visa to go and work do
some work in America they're covering
the road tour they're very specific on
the form and you had to fill it out and
if you didn't fill it out correctly I
didn't say it would have been thrown
back in my face it should be treated he
wants to be a an all a citizen of
America who's made that care
um he's married to an American citizen
and if you don't fill the forms out
correctly you you should be in hot water
I think that's fair you think it's fair
but do you think it's and we keep
mentioning this at the moment a
politicized issue I'm going to come
across to Earnest on this Earnest
because uh yeah we've seen a lot of
politicizers people claimed issues in
the last 24 hours Stateside but on this
what do you make of the claim that Harry
is being used as something of a
political Pawn here I'm just going to
give the context to our viewers because
this uh request for his documents to be
released by The Heritage foundations are
called the conservative think tank Harry
of course has quite close Democrat
connection so is he being used as a pawn
absolutely I think that there's a lot of
unnecessary presumption being driven by
conservatives over there in the UK and I
think that honestly they're being
disrespectful to our customs you know
who's to say that he did not go through
the process correctly why is there so
many assumptions based on things that
are written in his book I just think
that is really a bunch of people
politicizing a bunch to do about nothing
you know Prince Harry does not pose a
threat to the United States
um I don't think anyone would assume
that he shouldn't be able to enter based
on what what what is he doing he's not a
terrorist he doesn't pose any criminal
record that would suggest that he would
be an endangerment in America so I just
think the entire conversation is just
really a bunch of rubbish to be honest
well I don't want to oversimplify
Earnest but I do get the impression that
quite a lot of Americans do enjoy the
British royal family
to have uh Prince Harry even if he's not
quite in the royal family anymore over
there in the states
you know absolutely I think that he has
really embraced American culture
um he is very modern he's Progressive
and he really represents the kind of
spirit that a lot of um particularly
Millennials and Jin's ears
um look for in the public figure such as
him so I think he fits in quite well and
he has been in quite well I mean we have
big Hollywood Moguls like Tyler Perry
let him stay at his Mansion you know
it's he's he's he's one of us in a
certain sense uh Robert you want to
respond
but you know I think that what's
important here is transparency and it's
not a right-wing organizations trying to
talk about these things he's openly said
he's taking class A drugs and a number
of all these drugs
um he may well have said that I've done
it in the past with his form but I'm not
doing it now and if that's the case
that's fine look we've got the president
of the United States who's is in court
at the moment for for uh not so much
what he's uh not so much all the sort of
awful things that have been going on in
his life but for actually forced to find
documents and and that he's having an
answer to it so if there's nothing to
hide just share the document would say
thanks a lot yes I gotta say it's quite
a compelling argument when you line it
up against Trump but then U.S officials
apparently they can decide to wave
um any kind of discrepancy on the phone
I respect the US officials I mean U.S
officials are saying there is not a case
to answer here then you've got to
respect them the same as if an American
who'd a famous American who was applying
for citizenship in the United Kingdom
admitted to taking drugs and then got to
accept it then we'd have to respect the
British government too look I just want
to ask you about some comments that we
had today from Sarah Ferguson
um quite an interesting character of
course in the great Royal scheme of
things but when we talk about keeping
one foot in and one foot out of the
royal family she said in an interview
you can't really do that and she
obviously has made her position very
clear and she's sort of carved it out
quite cleverly I think in terms of
trying to be a normal person she's
obviously kept her title she's still got
a voice it seems to be the type of thing
you would think Megan and Harry would
want to go for but they haven't plowed
that path well I mean I know Sarah the
reality is has a very sensible person
the reality is too is that she never got
remarried and that's why she kept the
title doesn't feel no other reason if
she'd brutally married she had been
Sarah whoever
um that's for one foot in one foot out
um I think that's true I don't think you
can be half in the queen made that quite
clear but actually it's quite
interesting what's happened with Sarah
she was invited to
Christmas with the Royals with their two
daughters
by the king and queen and Sandra went
along with Andrew was there too because
it was a private family gathering
my feeling of all these things is is
that some you can't have it both ways so
what I do find odd about Harry and Megan
although I I wish them well and I really
think that it's great what he wants for
life he has I've known him since you're
a little boy I covered the story for 33
years what I would say is in the spirit
of America there's no need to have the
Duke Duchess of Sussex title you just be
Mr Mrs Mountain baton Windsor and
there's no need to call your kids prince
and princess because you know if you're
an American that's going against 1776
isn't it that's a really interesting
point Ernest and we did ask your opinion
on having the Royals over there but as
Robert laid out is it within the spirit
of America shouldn't they be behaving
like ordinary citizens what's your
thought
I mean they're not ordinary citizens
um so that's just intellectually
dishonest to try to hold them to a
standard that neither this is neither
the society to which they're living in
nor the public nor any of you all on
this set would actually do that that's
just intellectually dishonest and it's
actually quite frankly impossible so
we're not going to act as though all of
a sudden they can just shed a title and
so with the publicity or all of it will
die it will not die they are high
profile individuals
um at the end of the day United States
government thought that the Visa was
fine I think all of this interrogation
is a waste of time I think that they're
quite fine where they are and I think
you know it's so many more important
things going on in the world than
badgering about a Visa like come on he's
fine he's okay I don't think anyone in
this country thinks he's an endangerment
and it happens in other countries as
well and I just think that to continue
to belabor this argument he said drugs
12 times okay when it doesn't have
anything to do with now they're just
battering them get over it one you could
ask us to get over it but it's not going
away well there is the the point as
Robert's making of the legal documents
here um I I sort of see Ernest Point as
well of the belaboring to death as well
now Meghan Markle under increased
scrutiny uh because she's going to
receive an award
um at this event in New York next month
um given to her by a prominent feminist
who is also a good friend of hers as it
transpires and her critics asking is she
deserving of that award now when I look
at sort of the work that she's done and
she's carried out she has spoken out
about women
um she has done that type of thing but
her critics saying look she doesn't
really do that much well I mean on this
one I actually I feel that she does
deserve it um prior to marrying Prince
Harry she was quite she was out there on
this area she's been a ever since her
little girl she's been speaking out on
about feminism writing letters about
adverts that go wrong so yeah I don't
know what I would say is as a person
that runs a charity charity you know
myself you've also got to sell the
tickets and you know Meghan Markle is a
famous person they're also going to get
a royal throne in because Harriet turn
up and these fifteen thousand dollar
ticket tables will sell because she's
there and that's a good thing because it
empowers women and it empowers their
voice that has to be a good thing uh
that was my thought Robert exactly when
I saw it fifteen hundred dollars a
ticket 50 uh yeah 15 000 for the table
and of course putting Meghan Markle on
the ticket doesn't mean that they need
to get to sell it um however when it
comes to uh Meghan Markle and how she is
discussed in the United States Ernest
I'll come to you on this because Robert
brought up the point of uh kindness
early he's he's known the couple for a
very long time
um Piers Morgan's not in a seat tonight
he's been kind enough to give me the
seat for a few days whilst he's on
holiday I might take a slightly
different view of things I'm also a
woman of around Megan's age not too far
off
um but when it comes to the way that she
is criticized that she is looked at for
this award that she's going to be
receiving next month do you think she's
deserving this award do you think
somebody else should more should be
getting it
look I think she deserves the award to
be honest you know Awards within
themselves from organizations are always
you know strategic and political in
their own right you know there is a
level of Merit but at the end of the day
you know I I think anyone who is humble
that understands the system understands
that in certain cases does the means
justify it the reason why they're having
the awards is support a cause it's a
charity effort and so the reason why
people are going there is really to
support the mission and so I think in
deciding this as someone who's an organ
I'm a president of a journalism
organization in Philadelphia and you
know when we pick honorees we pick
people that you know we do believe
deserve recognition but we also think
about the impact and so what you can't
deny is that Meghan Markle has impact
and she's going to have the psych the
impact that's going to fill those seats
and raise a lot of money for a cause
that everyone should be behind so I
think
it's not about her I mean I I personally
will support anyone who wants to buy a
table and I think that if she is
you buy the table I'll buy one ticket
it's not gonna get a 50 000 table but I
might get a ticket with you
a little piece how about that gentlemen
I think we've had a slightly different
nature of debate uh this evening than
normal I hope Pearson's viewers aren't
disappointed that we've kind of found
some reconciliation on buying a table to
Meghan markle's charity event next month
now neither of us okay you didn't say
you win we're journalists we like to go
free oh yeah it's been fantastic we'll
cover it it's been a fantastic have you
both have so much for insights coming up
next on Pierce Morgan and censored does
the law need to be changed to exclude
trans women from some female only spaces
will it only heighten this already toxic
debate we're discussing that next
[Music]
thank you
very beloved
they're careful who is praying too
exactly it's just like some kind of
Submarine prime minister you're making
the case here now a MILF stands for
mother I'd like to I'm not going to say
the next word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read a
book
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show what is a woman
can you believe we're asking it but the
question has perhaps worryingly
dominated political debate in the last
few years it's certainly a question that
can be used to attract politicians
around the globe leaders we've seen them
squirming from head to toe let's just
say some answer the question where these
others really don't
I to be honest with Sean that's that
questions come slightly out of left
field for me
um
people Define themselves people Define
their own genders trans women are women
but in the present context there is no
automatic rate for a trans woman in our
context where our trans women is not a
woman no that is that is circumstances
in which a trans woman will be housed in
the male prison estate look I'm not
I don't think we can conduct this
debate with
you know sorry no no no it's just no no
I just
yeah I of course I know a woman who
adult human female
or this week Britain's prime minister
issue sooner you just saw him at the end
there when he was speaking to Piers
Morgan a few weeks ago he has pledged to
change the equality act here in the UK
to introduce legal protections for
biological women in same-sex spaces with
the move perhaps Banning trans women
from accessing Single Sex spaces is it
fair that's our question coming up now
joining me is transgender teacher and
journalist Debbie Hayton and Freda
Wallace from the Manchester LGBT
Foundation great to have you both with
us on this important issue
um you know what uh seeing that New
Zealand's uh leader there saying this
question is coming out of left field
that strikes me because it's really not
left field at the moment this is
absolutely mainstream debate and let's
just start with the very obvious change
that's being preserved proposed by the
conservative government here in the UK
at the moment uh Debbie I'll come to you
first is it a sensible move
I do think it's a sensible move uh trans
people have been let down badly in the
same way women have been let down badly
by badly uh worded laws that have
increasingly been based on feelings and
that's no basis of anybody's rights
trying to base those laws on feelings
has led to uncertainty it's led to
confusion and a lack of confidence in
the law we need to get back to reality
suppose that then to Freda about the
feelings point because what's the core
of this is changing the legal definition
legal protections for people depending
on their biological sex is what's
proposed rather than legal sex so what
do you make of Debbie's point there do
you think this is the sensible move
no it's not about feelings it's about
social reality and the way people
conduct the cells in social lives you
know like I you know no nobody cares how
I identify they just accept me as I am
you know and in my social life and my
real life the female friends I know the
CIS female friends I know don't have a
problem this is just it's political
maneuvering really and it's completely
unworkable I've had like distressed
emails today from trans women trans
young trans people actually that they're
worried that they're not going to be
able to live their lives they're not
going to be able to go into the toilets
that they always would have but it's
it's just a ridiculous scenario it's not
going to happen I would like to reassure
trans people out there this is
completely unworkable because for for to
to please this you would have to check
people you know are you going to check
whether somebody's male or female in a
public space it's just not workable it's
not realistic there is I see your point
there about the realisticness of it the
the common sense side of it how it's
actually going to be enforced but do you
accept um Freedom the reason this is
being brought up and the reason the
government is pushing hard for it is
because there have been a couple of
cases and I appreciate their small of
Bad actors that are kind of messing it
up for the rest
we feel unsafe
we don't base laws based on Bad actors
that mess it up for the rest there were
there were seven women convicted just
today of sex crimes you know it's got
nothing to do with whether you're trans
or not whether you're a perpetrator of
heinous crimes they always try and make
out that you know trans women are some
kind of threat you'll hear people like
Helen Joyce completely misinterpreting
this all the time it's just not our
reality works I'm afraid and it's like I
was hoping that Kelly J Keane was going
to be on this show tonight because she
is somebody that is like complete a
totally ridiculous person that's
fathered around the world by the far
right and it's like this is that this is
the level of ridiculousness this uh this
debate has got to now and it's uh you
know it's just she she was invited she
wasn't able to be here so she isn't able
because she's chickened out the
ridiculous person
well she is you know she's she's
somebody that traveled 11 000 miles to
get covered in soup and then came back
and claimed it was some kind of Victory
on this point because uh and I will come
back to
um very shortly Debbie but I just want
to come back to Frida on this because
the the way this conversation is going
you brought up some real concrete
examples there of you know emails you've
received today real life examples of
Trans women who are being impacted by
this decision but then starting to slam
people by calling them ridiculous isn't
this the kind of route that we go down
where this debate becomes so toxic so
aggressive and it actually undoes the
cause
I don't think so I think when you when
you're actually followed by the like if
you're followed by an organization
organization called Arts of Hulk Who
Tommy Robinson founded be followed by
those kind of people you deserve to have
everything thrown at you including soup
sorry that's just how it is I do
appreciate there is toxicity on both
sides of the debate look uh that we have
it feels like reached a Tipping Point in
this issue
um whereas a few years ago we've come
light years uh from you know people
being accused of being turfs obviously
that is a real and concrete concern uh
but also people wanting to speak up
about their own delicate issues
surrounding rights and women's rights as
well so talk to me about what you're
seeing where we are along that Tipping
Point when it comes to trans rights but
also defending the rights of women
well we're in a position where trans
rights were as I said dependent on
feelings we made an assertion and
everybody just believed us uh now the
boot seems to be on the other foot women
are ex women are asserting their
feelings unrightly so uh but feelings
are not a basis of law we need to come
back to reality uh we need to respect
women and women's verses if you know if
we uh if we claim to identify with women
then we should respect their spaces we
shouldn't go uh and take those verses
from them and uh talking about young
trans people I just regret that the uh
the false promises that have been made
young people have been told that they
can change sex or they can be the
opposite sex I can tell you as a science
teacher it's just not true and the
problem is that young people have been
made promises that nobody can uh nobody
can keep and it's not the best is to go
forwards we need to come back to reality
we need to come back to science and we
need to base laws on what we can measure
and what we can see which is biological
sex and and just stay with you for a
second Debbie because there's some I
want to ask you if you think you see any
issues with this proposed government
change the equality act because there
are some interesting points one being
brought up by the uh a quality Watchdog
to the government saying this changed so
the ACT could actually make it easier
for Trans men to bring pay
discrimination cases because they'll be
judged on their biological sex which was
woman
um it's definitely tricky ground to
tread do you see any kind of
complications coming along if it is if
it is enforced
well we need we need a property book we
need to listen to each other and we need
to talk but by removing laws back to
what is objective what is concrete and
what is real is the best is to be moving
forwards and you you're quite right to
point out about trans men there's also
the issue about it as it stands trans
men find it very difficult to uh uh to
uh exert the rights under a pregnancy
and maternity because the where the law
is written and it's because of think
issues like this that we need to come
back and we need to just analyze what
the law is actually there for and how we
can best apply it I'm glad you brought
up the issue of trans men there as well
or in their cause because it this law
would apply to both trans men and trans
women when it comes to this idea of
biological sex points and the legal
protections of those uh Freda back to
you if I can because
Debbie was making the point there that
as a trans woman she would like to be on
the side of women and understand where
they're coming in at this debate so talk
to me from the point of view of your
organization and the activism you do
where women fit into that
well we we include all women from all
walks of life and there are so many
diverse types of women and it's like I
just don't understand what Debbie is
waffling on about she's represent she
represents an organization called the
LGB Alliance that actually don't like
Debbie at all they pretend to an
investigation by Ben Hunt Vice magazine
revealed them to been like in tampering
with the ehrc the actual laws that you
know that you're talking about now it's
a it's total corruption that's going on
and it plays into the hands of people
like Lee Anderson who is already saying
that he'll use this issue for the next
election since people are being used as
a political football and Debbie I mean
does Debbie identify as a woman is she
Mr Debbie I don't know how she conducts
herself in social life but it's not
realistic is it in any sense the Debbie
to identify as a woman and then say she
shouldn't be allowed in female spaces
Freda I mean I'm taking issue with the
way some of these personal attacks are
being directed Debbie but I'm going to
allow Debbie to respond
uh can I just say that I don't represent
the LGB Alliance at all that that's
that's that's just not true and I I go
about my life as Debbie I uh I I you
know this this is this is this is this
is not an issue I don't identify as a
woman you know women or female
I'm Dr Debbie so you're Mr Debbie you're
not Mrs Mrs Debbie Hayton no I'm Dr
Debbie hidden so I said so but doctor
isn't a sex a sex delineation is it
oh so who are you
are you missed are you Mr Debbie Hayton
uh why why is this an issue why is this
an issue because it's important because
this is this is the delineation we have
in society if you're gonna start calling
yourself Mr Debbie you're going to have
a lot of problems there accessing female
spaces or even male spaces
I I don't access female Space versus
Freedom it be wrong for us I won't do
that those are for women
you're a ridiculous per you don't
represent anything Debbie be realistic I
I want to end this conversation here
because uh I don't actually uh think
it's very nice
um the personal tax that we've had on
Debbie this evening I want to thank you
Debbie for sharing your experience with
us I'm not taking either side in the
debate but Frida when we take into
context what is being done to try and
fight for Trans rights at the moment and
for the rights of women it's a toxicity
of this type of debate that seems to be
holding everything back but I want to
thank you both your insights this
evening we're gonna wrap things up there
Freedom Debbie thanks so much coming up
next here on first Morgan uncenservice
all the drama and Chaos surrounding
Donald Trump's arrest one key figure's
been missing Melania where is the former
president's long-suffering wife and all
this we'll see if we can find out next
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan and censor
thanks for bearing with me whilst pears
is on holiday Rosanna look we're back in
the studio for you for the next few days
now we are back to talking about former
president Donald Trump because when he
became president he reveled in
surrounding himself with a coastery of
Hangers On advisors and secret service
but entering the courthouse yesterday
look at him here he struck a lonely
figure no one to even open a door for
him bet he didn't like that in times
like these most of us would turn to
family but one person noticeably absent
from his side yesterday his
long-standing and some might say
long-suffering wife Melania Trump
since leaving the White House the former
first ladies barely been seen in public
or with her husband and last night the
Donald raised a few eyebrows after he
made a glaring Omission in his speech
Let's Take a look
I have a son here who's done a great job
and I have another son here who's done a
great job
and Ivanka and baron will be great some
days tall he is tall and he's smart
but I have a great family and they've
done a fantastic job
uh Donald you forgot to mention your
wife
or a wife so is the
marriage rock solid or is it on the
Rocks there's a question swirling around
today joining me to discuss all this Fox
News contributed to an outkick host
Tommy Lauren and by Manhattan criminal
attorney and former Apprentice
contestant Stacy Schneider Tommy and
Stacy thanks so much for joining us on
this potentially not the most important
issue of what is currently going down in
your justice system at the moment but it
has been something that's caught
attention we thought get you two smart
women on to talk about another smart
woman Melania Trump I would argue
um Tommy let let's come to you first
should she have been there do you
understand why she wasn't
well I'm a country music fan so we know
that you're supposed to Stand By Your
Man but listen this is understandable
let's talk about the charges against him
although I think that they are BS it
revolves around hush money payments to a
porn star so I think Melania rightfully
so maybe has some sour grapes over this
and can you really blame her but I think
this really goes back to I think Milani
is much more private person I think
Donald Trump of course he loves the
Limelight he loves the spotlight he
wants to be in front of people talking
to the American people and I think
Melania quite frankly is probably sick
of the drama she probably wants to stay
home at Mar-A-Lago and enjoy her life
and if we're all being honest maybe she
doesn't want Donald Trump to run again
in 2024 maybe she wants to have a
quieter life I don't think this means
that there's trouble in their marriage I
just think that Melania she'd rather sit
on the side maybe on this one I think
you're going to see her hitting the
campaign Trail just as you said in the
last two elections but you know
rightfully so maybe she wanted to sit
this one out considering the context of
the situation Stacy that seems like a
fair argument to me I mean if you knew
that your husband Burns was about to be
publicly humiliated for multiple
extramarital relationships allegations
of children born out of wedlock wouldn't
be that comfortable being in the
courtroom
it wouldn't be comfortable but it's
really not good for Donald Trump that
she's not there and especially as this
case proceeds there's a row in the
courtroom the front row the first row
where family is expected to sit and
support the defendant who's now indicted
and it's especially important when this
case goes to trial and Donald Trump has
said he's taking it all the way and
going to trial on it that his wife or
his family is sitting in that row
supporting him the jury looks to see
who's there to support the defendant it
softens the defendant and it's not good
for him that his marriage is in this
state but like Tommy said I don't
I don't blame her I think political
wives are no longer coming up and
standing at those press conferences and
getting next to their husband while
they're at the microphone disavowing
whatever they've been accused of the
times have changed I don't blame Melania
I I'll come back to Tommy shortly but
Stacy I just wanted to ask you how you
felt about Melania when she was first
lady do you think she was a good
representative for your country
no
um I mean I obviously know of Melania
I'm a born and bred New Yorker I was on
the show
um
I think Melania was probably the least
likely first lady I've ever seen some of
the things that came out about her after
the fact like when she went to visit
um the children on the border who were
in cages and some of the statements that
came out or got leaked out and the tapes
her reaction to Christmas at the White
House thought that was very surprising I
think she gets a lot more credit than I
would have expected her to have gotten
and I think she's getting the credit
just because she's the wife of Donald
Trump and people supports Donald Trump I
appreciate you giving you abuse that uh
Tommy coming to you that do you think it
sort of silence is golden when it comes
to Milan she's not the been the most
vocal the most outspoken first lady she
did do a few sort of causes and a few
photo ops and things like that but do
you think she played a smart move by
just being very quiet and now very
absent
that's her personality but I'd like to
go back to her getting more credit than
she deserves I mean you've got to be
kidding me here every other first lady
has been put up on a pedestal on the
cover of Vogue and you have an actual
model who was completely snubbed and
looked over so I completely disagree
with that that she got more credit she
got far less credit than she deserves
she's a smart woman she doesn't like the
attention she doesn't like the spotlight
she has that ability to maybe not split
herself in the spotlight that is every
bit her right but again because this
case is such a sham anyway going back to
this point about how the jury is going
to look and see if she's there this case
is such a nothing burger and such a
waste of time I don't think that's even
going to factor in this is a Witch Hunt
against Donald Trump I think his family
supports him whether it's in front of
the public eye or not I think he has the
support of the entire Trump family and
millions of Americans by this one I have
one comment about that I don't think
it's really that important whether or
not our first lady makes the cover of
Vogue or doesn't that kind of disrespect
I don't really consider that to be much
to make anything about it's a little bit
embarrassing actually but I'll tell you
something about the case now the
indictment I originally felt yesterday
when I when the indictment was released
and I read the Bare Bones indictment and
all of the legal pundits I've been
talking about it's so Bare Bones there's
nothing there there are no surprises
well I feel differently now about it I
am surprised I read the DA's statement
of facts which were released and those
are the facts that are backing up the
reasons why they feel they can meet the
elements of this crime which is 34
counts felony counts of falsification of
a business record
I was pleasant I have to say pleasantly
surprised not because I don't want to
see someone convicted of something they
didn't do but because if he did do what
they're accusing him of they actually
dotted their eyes and crossed their T's
very well and that's laid out in the
statement of facts there are actually
there's evidence listed in there that we
weren't really made aware of even
yesterday when the district attorney got
up and had made a press conference and
basically stated what his case was it
sounded weak it sounded not good it
sounded like you know uh sort of a
frivolous prosecution but if you look at
this statement of facts
and you see that there are phone calls
there are business ledgers there are
checks there are things being issued in
and out of the Donald J Trump revocable
trust there are um uh there's conduct
that affects a business's his businesses
the Trump organization which is located
in the state of New York
I think this is going to be more than
people think it is when the truth starts
coming out yeah I appreciate you laying
that out uh stated because I had a
similar feeling Tommy actually when I
read through the statement of facts last
night and I want to get your reaction to
because I understand your position on
this is very watertight in terms of
supporting Trump saying it's a
politically motivated Witch Hunt but
when you read through these 34 counts as
they were laid out you know the the
catch and kill scheme as it was called
to try and stop information suppress
information by American Media Inc uh
you've got multiple allegations of
women's information being suppressed how
do you read that and feel okay with it
listen we're talking about a Manhattan
D.A that downgraded 52 of felonies to
misdemeanors and he's going after Donald
Trump for what amounts to a clerical
error and a trumped-up NDA to a porn
star you have got to be kidding me how
do you explain that and the spending of
federal money on that are taxpayer
dollars to do this when New Yorkers are
wandering around the streets of that
City worried about their safety and
their personal safety and their family
safety this is an absolute Sham this is
weaponization political persecution not
prosecution and Trump will prevail as he
always does you both laid out your sides
here and you've been both very very
clear about that I just want to round
off this conversation because I feel
like the political Witch Hunt side of
things whether it is or not has been
done stuff the last day and we got you
both on to talk about the Trump family
as it is so Ivanka Trump just finally
somebody who sort of seemed to take a
bit of a step back did get a mention in
Trump's speech that do we expect to see
more of a banker in coming weeks and
months do you think Stacy
no I think she's going to lay low and
remain laying low down in Florida you
know don't forget she grew up in New
York all her friends were here you know
sort of the the scuttlebutt here is
nobody wants to talk to her anymore they
don't like what went on when she was in
the white house they don't like that she
um was quiet when that people felt she
should have spoken up especially since
she had taken on this so-called senior
role in the white house without very
much experience
um in any governmental Affairs so I
think she's trying to
um
compensate and bring her brand back a
little bit because she's really been
ousted from a lot of Social Circles
where she grew up and I don't think she
wants to touch this issue I think she
and her husband want to move on and get
into something else and not be pulled
into the orbit of the circus told me is
that fat characterization
well I disagree that she left New York
because she's embarrassed a lot of
people left New York and because it's a
hell hole to live in a lot of people
moved to Florida because they have a
great governor and a lot of freedom so
that's beside the point but I will say
this I think Ivanka has other
aspirations maybe she doesn't want to be
in the white house again maybe she
doesn't want to be in the political
Arena that's every bit her right it
doesn't mean she doesn't support her dad
just means maybe this isn't the role
that she wants anymore I think we're
looking far too much into this I think
the Trump family is behind Donald Trump
whether like I said whether they want to
be out in the lights like Eric and Don
whether they want to be more in the
shadows like Ivanka and Melania I don't
think this means much look I wish we had
time to get Stacy's responsive point
about New York and your comments on New
York because there but I'm sure we can
guess what they would be New York one of
the best cities in the world Florida a
very nice place too thank you both so
much Tommy and Stacy for joining us
next tonight the gender pay Gap in
British workplaces eight in ten firms
still paying women less than men will
discuss that after the break
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read a
book
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it we're talking
about it Piers Morgan uncensored Monday
to Thursday at 8pm on talk TV
[Music]
and coming up on the talk King Charles
cements Camilla's place at the top of
the royal pecking order by granting her
that title of Queen and police launch
morning raids on SMP headquarters and
Nicholas sturgeon's home arresting her
husband as part of a probe into party
finances and channel 4's new sex
education series comes Under Fire for
showing adults stripping off in front of
children all of that and more at nine
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Pierce Morgan downstairs
with me Rosanna Lockwood city of appears
for a couple days he's on holiday thanks
for joining us in the studio we do have
Piers regulars Paula Ron Adrian and
Richard Thai so wonderful to have you
both with us to chew through some
stories of the day uh and I opened the
show by talking about sort of
proprietary at propriety and decorum and
class basically bemoaning where is it
gone given that we're seeing a former US
president sat in court facing 34 counts
uh and then this morning the SMP
unbelievable to wake up to this news uh
Peter Morrell Nicholas sturgeon's
husband being arrested we must say he
has just been released without charge
and we do need to talk about this
carefully it's an ongoing investigation
into the party's uh finances but let's
begin Richard by just getting your
reaction to the news this morning the
site of police tents appearing outside
the surgeon home is just shocking I mean
truly shocking for such a high profile
long-standing many people would say
whether you agree with her politics or
not very successful politician truly
shocking the question then is what
happens from now you've got the
investigation on one side but more
importantly for Scotland what does it
mean for the SMP what does it mean for
Independence my hunt Rosanna is this is
a massive opportunity for the other
independence party Alba and Alex Hammond
I suspect he's literally licking his
lips at the smps problems their
potential demise because if you are a
genuine Scottish nationalist rather look
at a unionist party surely you're going
to look at the other independence party
this isn't again I'm going to be so
careful but you know around the Trump
situation very very different of course
but politically motivated Witch Hunt
that's how the narrative has been taken
by the Trump campaign in order to Define
that do you think this risks being
politicized in itself oh so what do you
think I don't think it can and I I think
to answer your question what was most
shocking we know that the investigation
was ongoing we've known since at least
last year July that there's been this
investigation and what the investigation
surrounded
but to suddenly have it turn up on the
doorstep of Nicholas sturgeon in the way
that it did that was the shock and on
top of that you may not remember but at
her Comfort at her press conference
forgive me when she was resigning she
was actually asked the question and she
refused to answer and I mean they've
been these uh rumors circulating for
months and months and months I mean I
had my own experience with the SMP back
in December 19.
um sorry in May 19 and I ended up suing
a a newly elected Scottish MEP for
calling me
um you know some pretty obscene things
live on air and there were question
marks then about when they had to settle
out of course and make a donation to
charity and the question where did the
money come from so there's all sorts of
allegations this has been rumbling this
has been reported on for for months and
months if not years and suddenly it's
absolutely exploded into uh the public
Consciousness yes and I can tell you uh
you know to add to the shock uh for the
police they would have been
investigating this thoroughly okay this
isn't something that they would have
just thought about and just said over
some Cups of Tea let's go and knock on
Nicola's door tomorrow this is something
that would have been planned and would
have been purposeful and that is why
it's called such a shock I think around
the political Arena yeah the images of
the police fans outside of the
headquarters outside of the home like
you said Paula it doesn't just happen
overnight and what does it do to
Scottish voters trust in the party that
has led Scotland for 15 16 years or so
and do they then say well I can't trust
them therefore I can't trust the whole
concept of Independence or did they say
I'm going to look at the other
independence party absolutely
fascinating but but truly truly shocking
the ramifications I think you're right
there they're going to Ripple on for
some time yet let's rip on this
conversation before we find ourselves in
lead legal hot water our lawyers
standing by Paula luckily in the CIA to
make sure that we don't ready to protect
but we did promise to view a little
discussion about the gender pay Gap
because this study eight out of 10
companies pay men more than women this
is data recorded by the BBC
um fascinating stuff things really
aren't moving on Paula you and I had a
conversation in the makeup chairs just
last week about the gender pay Gap about
sexism in our Industries and where we
feel it nicer to you I have felt it in
gender pay Gap throughout my
broadcasting career talk to us about
your experience in the legal point of
view well the biggest issue is secrecy
so I couldn't tell you
I could give you some broad statistics
but I couldn't tell you specifically and
of course the broad stats will tell you
that men male barristers are paid more
than female barristers and you wouldn't
be surprised to hear that and you
wouldn't be surprised to hear that the
lowest paid are black female barristers
now I bet you Richard don't have a
conversation with peers in the makeup
chair about the gender payback that is a
good and doesn't that sum up but what's
the issue here I'm making an assumption
but but in my other discussion with
peers I mean you know peers has paid
more than me so that's that's the sort
of discussion it's just a different
approach let's leave that there
um look I think it is extraordinary this
it is five or six years but actually the
BBC data they haven't really released
the full you know a full sort of data
set so we can really drill into it it's
more than just the pay Gap though it's
about actually
um what's the balance between men and
women at work has that shifted at all
because that's obviously uh was was a
key part of the objectives of some of
this some say at nine percent I mean
that's getting quite close to the point
where you can barely measure it so yeah
I think there's lots of questions about
this and a huge amount of effort I mean
I've sat on Boards of companies of
Charities where this has been looked at
incredibly seriously really
conscientiously and it is yeah some may
say it's incredibly disappointed it
hasn't made any difference and so how do
we make a difference because it's one
thing to discuss isn't it one thing for
us to chat in the makeup chair but how
do we change this and we need to be
radical don't we we need to say okay
that men's pay needs to be publicized
well that's that's was going to be my
question Richard because I I hear your
point on progress great work sitting on
the boards as well uh but is
transparency the answer because of
course from the BBC fan itself and the
gender pay Gap hot water a few years ago
they ended up publishing
um the salaries of topics but the truth
is actually in listed companies and
indeed in private companies lots of paid
of directors that is publicized it's
publicized specifically for board
directors uh it's publicized in band for
for Senior Management so there is
already lots and lots of reporting I
think in a sense all I would say is in
my experience in the last five plus
years on Boards of directors there's
been a massive focus on this uh in in
board papers and things so in a sense I
probably slightly surprised it hasn't
seen some form of shift but I really
want to see the whole data set before
really forming a a comprehensive
judgment I wonder if the BBC have been
perhaps just a little bit selective on
the information you wouldn't accuse him
of that on this network look before we
finish up the show I want to bring us
back to the theme of class and decorum
if we may end it there I want you to
select
um the member of the royal family now
this isn't me being tried it's because
I'm talking about Sarah Ferguson Ali she
gave an interview where she was talking
about having one foot in one foot at the
royal family and the importance of
kindness are she wins my award today for
class and Decor even though she's not
really in the royal family anymore um
Paula who who for you classiest member
oh I well I want to say Dead or Alive
dead would be the queen mother yep
um and alive I I would have to say
um
I'd probably say Prince Edward actually
in Sophie Richard quickly I I'm actually
with the queen consorts who I'm still
calling the concert I can't quite get to
the queen yet I'm sure we'll do that is
it from us sorry we have to wrap out of
there whatever you're doing tonight make
sure it is uncensored good night thank
you
[Music]
thank you
very beloved and let us Pride yeah
careful who are we praying too exactly
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it